[Music]  [Music]  I know my game is  cigarette she's getting up lunch  [Music]  Oh No I'm freaking out Arden my best  friend all I gotta do is find a part to  fix your game everything goes back to  the way it was  [Music]  your mommy don't wanna hear my bingo  [Music]  housewives wanna meet you do want to get  rich playing video games slaughter race  he's wicked dangerous attention to  details pretty impressive  well well well who are you I think we  should get out of here  Showtime that's right  I love it here who knew there's so many  babies and cats in the world  I want this to be my life  I don't think I could ever tell her Alf  there's no law saying best friends have  to have the same dreams  [Music]  this is what's called the darknet are  you sure this safe just whatever you do  do not look at his little brother what  are you doing here hmm the reason I came  to your neck of the face I mean there's  a face in your neck I mean woods neck of  the woods  [Music]